car three brings back lightning McQueen
for the third installment in Pixar's
Cars trilogy and like all Pixar films
it's loaded with Pixar and Disney Easter
eggs like the Pizza Planet truck and
Cinderella's carriage yip UK movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
I'll be revealing where all the usual
Pixar Easter eggs including a113 are
hidden as well as in covering some more
obscure ones and how the movie fits in
with the Pixar theory
I'm also kicking off my very special car
three giveaway two lucky winners will
get this awesome the art of car three
hardback book which shows off some of
Pixar's amazing concept art storyboards
and exclusive insights into the making
of the movie for a chance to win just
subscribe and leave a comment about the
film and also answer the question I'll
be asking later in the video quick
warning there are spoilers ahead for
cars three so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet let's start with the
Pizza Planet truck which debuted in
Pixar's first feature Toy Story and
which has appeared in almost every Pixar
film to date in the card universe the
Pizza Planet truck is actually a
character called Todd and in the first
movie he appeared as an onlooker at the
Los Angeles International Speedway he
cameo twice in cars 2 the first time
appearing on TV and the second as a
spectator at the Radiator Springs Grand
Prix and in car 3 Pizza Planet truck
Todd is a participant in the Crazy eight
demolition derby and in this movie the
Pizza Planet truck rocket actually flies
into the crowd at one point mr. Issa is
a cool new character we meet in car 3
through collects the license plates of
each of the opponents she defeats at the
Thunder Hollow Speedway Miss Frisco also
carries a street sign that appears to
read West cutting Boulevard and Easter
Egg to the location of Pixar's former
headquarters in Richmond California and
this street sign last appeared in Toy
Story 3 above the door in Andy's bedroom
also on the side of Miss Fresa is the
number 58 which the animators included
as a reference of the Year mistress a
voice actress Lea delaria was born and
the name of deloria's high school is
also on the bus by the way I wonder if
Miss Fritton name is a play on this
Frizzle who drives the Magic School Bus
in the animated TV series of the same
name the Pixar luxo ball is also in the
demolition derby race painted on one of
the
cause participating in the race at the
Thunder Hollow Speedway the luxo ball of
course goes back to picks off very first
short look so junior which features both
the luxo ball and two desk lamps one of
which appears in Pixar's logo there's
also a couple of a113 Easter eggs in
class three you can see one on the press
sticker that Shannon's folks were on her
side
spoke to the on-track reporter who's
voiced by real-life sports reporter
Shannon spake and a113 is also the
number of Sterling's office as a Rusty's
Racing Center the a113 Easter Egg has
appeared in every single Pixar movie to
date and it's an emerged the classroom
at California Institute of the Arts
where the likes of Pixar's John Lasseter
studied and this one's quite hard to
spot but inside Sterling's office hidden
among the trophies is Cinderella's
pumpkin carriage and could this be an
Easter Egg to the tree from a bug's life
which also appeared previously in Earth
and Toy Story 2 back at Thunder hollow
speedways as a sneaky easter egg to car
3 production designer bill cone on the
wild bill's racing home billboard which
you can spot in the background here and
I wonder whether Wild Bill also provided
the cones for Sully's Kovach own motel
and Radiator Springs an important Easter
egg in class 3 that links the movie to
John knew bronies Pixar theory is the
first appearance of by-and-large
aka BNL and a card feature film where it
appears as a track sponsor at a Speedway
BNL is the corporation in wall-e that
basically enabled the pollution of the
planet and sent humans away from Earth
while it attempted to clear it up the
Pixar theory suggests that cars takes
place after humans leave the planet and
before a time hundreds of years later in
the events of wall-e take place and the
presence of by and large is a racetrack
sponsoring cars three supports the
suggested timeline racer number 31 Terry
kaga is sponsored by triple dent gum the
chewing gum from inside out with the
recurring jingle that plays throughout
that movie Pixar's lucky charm John
Ratzenberger returns in car 3 as the
voice of the truck Mack and there's a
scene with Mack in the movie which
includes a very sneaky and obscure
NASCAR Easter Egg
before going to the demolition derby at
Thunder Hollow Speedway matt and
lightning decide they want to go
incognito to his disguise
cheese's ago as a Jocko Flaco party
supplies truck which is an awesome
reference to the real-life monkey called
Jocko Flaco the race with NASCAR champ
Tim flock Jocko Flaco and Tim flocks
drove together in eight races in 1953
including flops grand national winners
Hickory Motor Speedway by the way I
wonder whether the clown on Macs truck
disguise is also a reference to jangles
the clown that Riley fears in inside out
car three also pays homage to NASCAR's
roots in Prohibition era bootlegging for
the moonshine still that appears in the
background of a scene in the woods and
those origins also get a nod in the
character of jr. midnight moon who is
voiced by NASCAR legend Robert Glenn jr.
Johnson who got his start in racing by
making moonshine runs through the
mountains of North Carolina and more
recently teamed up with a distillery to
share his family moonshine recipe which
is sold as midnight moon I also like
this shot in the woods of lightning in
silhouette leaping across the full moon
which not only has a kind of et vibe to
it but also made me think back to the
first card movie where we saw mater in
silhouette leaping across the face of a
full moon and talking of classic movies
I think this shades of Rocky's story in
the scenes of lightning training on the
beach the way he's competing against a
new younger rival and how he has to go
back to the drawing board to figure out
what he needs to do to win and also how
he has to get himself a new trainer
as always Pixar I've included an Easter
Egg to their upcoming movie in the
current film after car three Pixar is
releasing cocoa a Mexican Day of the
Dead story there's already a Karthi stir
egg in cocoa where a young boy is
wearing a pair of shoes that's brought
some lightning mcqueen stylings and car
3 director brian c has confirmed there
are two cocoa easter eggs in his movie
one of which appears at the Russkies
Racing Center when a homesick car thinks
of home and a picture of the town from
Cocoa appears on one of the training TV
screens and there's a second nod to
cocoa in the background vanilla scene
when a car is onstage singing there's a
fabulous Thermage two Doc Hudson aka the
fabulous Hudson Hornet when lightening
changes his number and colors to docs
and reveals he's now the fabulous
lightning McQueen so which was your
favorite Easter Egg in cars three and
were there any spotted that I missed and
what did
think of the movie for a chance to win
this awesome the art of cars 3 hardback
book be sure to subscribe and leave a
comment about the movie and also answer
the following question what was the
nascar monkey called who's named
features on max disguise make sure you
turn on your notifications to get all my
new cars 3 and pixar videos and i'll be
announcing the winners for the giveaway
on an upcoming video congratulations to
the 5 winners of my recent guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 giveaway who are on the
screen now and if you one of them send
me a message on youtube or via my email
which you can find on my about page so I
can get your details to send you the
prize if you enjoyed this I really
appreciate you hitting that thumbs up
button and check out some more of my
Pixar and Easter Egg videos right here
thanks for watching and see you next
time you became movie lovers